Los niveles de vida, de calidad de vida
que se alcanzó
se Han conocido en Europa
porque si hay estado en el bienestar
o había estado en el bienestar
en la Europa capitalista,
en la Europa Occidental
era por miedo de que hubiera 1 revolución proletaria.
Y esta es la realidad
y cada vez la gente en la Europa Occidental
es más pobre y más miserable,
que les llegó el capitalismo más salvaje,
sin ningún tipo de derechos, de nada.
¿A ver cómo vivían mejor
eh? Porque si tan mala era no hace falta este gasto.
¿Por qué? Pues porque tenía 1 nivel de vida mejor,
1 esperanza de vida mejor,
1 sanidad gratuita y universal. Cosa
porque la dedicación era gratuita y universal,
porque todo el Mundo tenía trabajo,
porque no había diferencias sociales
y porque la gente era ya que hablábamos el otro día
de felicidad. Pues la gente era feliz a su manera,
porque los la felicidad material
la tenía cubierta y no tenía que preocuparse,
o se le iban a desahuciar de su casa
o le iban a cortar la luz
o le iban a cortar el agua
porque no había gente durmiendo por la calle,
cosa qué porque no había problemas de violencia,
empezó a haber problemas de violencia
cuando se cayó aquello
el último año, que ya.
Esas son las realidades del barquero y por lo tanto
tenemos que seguir
eh con el rollo, tenemos que seguir con la milonga,
tenemos que seguir con la pamplina De cada día,
de escuchar dictaduras,
etc.,
etc. etc. como si en los demás países hubiera mucha